bob's in fort lauderdale hey bob how are
you
i'm doing fabulous how are you guys
doing better than i deserve how can i
help
well i've got a weird dilemma i am
retired but i have a very sweet
part-time job and that part-time job
takes me on the road for about a
thousand miles a week
and my car is about
getting close to the end of its life so
i'm
wrestling in my mind whether to buy a
new car
lease a new car or just rent a car on
the two days that i'm out on the road
okay leasing is out the option
lacing is not a good option because then
you're going to run the mileage up over
and it's going to blow up the deal
it's going to make it not here's the
thing when you put that many miles on a
car
you all of us can agree it's going to go
down in value
very very quickly agreed probably in
about a month
yeah for real so if you lease a car
they're not going to lose money on the
lease they're not stupid
so the lease is structured in such a way
that if you
do something to the car that causes it
to lose that much value
like put miles on it or more than normal
wear and tear
it affects what you get when you turn it
in because they're going to hammer you
with being over on your miles and the
lease is not going to work
in other words you're going to pay for
the lost value in the lease
a hundred percent of the time so that
doesn't work
the renting a car might work if you
catch one of the rental car people
where they're not doing their math well
but in theory
they're going to put some kind of
limitation on you to keep you from doing
to their car what you are doing to yours
which is destroy its value
right so so what you so what you're
saying is that you're not gonna hide the
[ __ ] you're not gonna hide the pee it's
under one of the shells
okay that usually now again you
might catch a rental car company that
didn't put some kind of limitation on
you since it's two days a week
and this is probably you're probably not
doing this for 10 years or something
uh but but what i what you're probably
you're probably your cheapest
mathematical option
is to buy an inexpensive car 10 000
or so that you just use for this because
you're destroying this old
uh honda accord's value or this old uh
maximus value or impalas value or
focuses value or not a focus you don't
spend that much time in a focus but
um but you know whatever but i mean
something medium-sized that's reasonably
comfortable
yeah but you're just knowing that you're
just you're you're
wearing this thing out it's a cost of
doing business